así que aquí tenemos las reglas para la
nomenclatura de los arcanos y de los
ciclos arcanos así que primero tenemos
que encontrar la cadena de carbono más
larga y ponerle un nombre así que vamos
a hacer esto con este primer ejemplo
podemos ver que aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 y 5
carbonos así que este este alcano en
principio tiene digamos como nombre
principal el venta no verdad y ahora nos
dice hay que enumerar la cadena para
asignarle a los sustituye entes el
número más pequeño posible así que por
ejemplo podríamos enumerar lo de
izquierda a derecha o de derecha a
izquierda si empezamos a la izquierda
que nos queda 1 2 3 4 5 verdad y este
sustituyen te queda en el carbono 2 si
empezáramos de derecha a izquierda
entonces sería 1 2 3 4 y este mismo
sustituyen te quedaría en el carbono 4
así que esta enumeración es la correcta
ahora hay que ir hay que identificarlos
sustituye entes y asignarles un nombre y
sólo tenemos un sustituye ente que es
y metil verdad un grupo metilo así que
finalmente este este es este arcano se
llama 2 metil debería ponerlo junto
verdad
por lo más juntos dos metil ventana
verdad y por supuesto no hay que
acomodar los sustituye antes por orden
alfabético porque pues sólo tenemos una
verdad entonces es el único que vamos a
tener vamos a ver el siguiente ejemplo
que hay aquí tenemos este ejemplo y
vamos a hacer exactamente lo mismo
primero tenemos que encontrar la cadena
más larga que podemos ver fácilmente que
es esta verdad que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 y
átomos de carbono entonces este en
principio sería un hexano ahora hay que
ubicar cuáles son nuestros grupos
sustituye entes y podemos ver que
tenemos 2 2 2 grupos metilo verdad y
antes de eso habría que enumerar esta
cadena pero es muy fácil ver que si
enumeramos de izquierda a derecha
tenemos digamos en el número en el
carbono 2 aparecen los primeros
sustituye entes que si fuera al revés
aparecerían en el carbono 4 verdad no
más bien 1 2 3 4 5 en el carbono
muy bien entonces esta es la forma
correcta de enumerar y estos son dos
metidos por lo tanto este se va a llamar
22 dimetil hexano ok y entonces algo que
hay que acordarnos muy bien es el
prefijo vamos a poner un prefijo siempre
que tengamos varios metilo so varios
grupos grupos sustituye entes iguales
verdad por ejemplo si tenemos dos pues
tendremos que poner el prefijo y si
tenemos tres será el prefijo tres sí
tenemos cuatro será el el prefijo tetra
si tenemos cinco pues sería el prefijo
penta y si tenemos seis sería el prefijo
exa y así sucesivamente verdad entonces
este este al k no se le conoce como 2,2
dimetil hexano vamos a ver el siguiente
ejemplo este siguiente ejemplo aquí
nuevamente nuestro primer punto es
encontrar nuestra cadena más larga y si
nos damos cuenta este tiene uno
3 4 5 6 y 7 entonces este nuevamente
bueno no nuevamente sino este podemos
identificar que es un ept a no muy bien
ahora como vamos a enumerar esta cadena
pues si nos damos cuenta si empezamos
ahora de izquierda a derecha el primer
sustituyen te aparece en el carbono 4
mientras que si ordenamos de derecha a
izquierda el primero aparece en el
segundo verdad entonces empezamos aquí 1
2 3 4 5 6 y 7 verdad y ahora si tenemos
varios sustituye entes grupos grupos
sustituye entes aquí tenemos un grupo
metilo y aquí tenemos un grupo que tildó
muy bien entonces tenemos un grupo
metilo y un grupo estilo y lo que nos
dice el cuarto punto en estas reglas es
acomodar los sustituye entes por orden
alfabético entonces si queremos
ordenarlos por orden alfabético tenemos
metil un grupo metilo que empieza con m
y un grupo
que empieza con él entonces sabemos que
él la eba antes que la m y entonces esto
sería un 4 útil y sería un 2 metil hay
que apretar un poquito un 2 metil eta no
muy bien entonces esta es la forma según
yu pack para asignarle un nombre a esta
molécula vamos a ver nuestro siguiente
ejemplo y de hecho aquí pongo dos copias
porque hay que hacer un poquito más de
análisis verdad entonces si nos damos
cuenta de estas dos son iguales y si
encontramos la cadena más larga de uno
pues ese será exactamente la misma para
la otra verdad entonces podemos ver que
se está y tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 entonces
esta molécula va a ser un octano
octano en cualquiera de estos dos casos
verdad ahorita veremos cuál es la
nomenclatura correcta entonces hay dos
formas de asignarle un nombre si
empezamos de izquierda a derecha o de
derecha a izquierda verdad entonces por
ejemplo si empezamos de derecha a
izquierda perdón de izquierda a derecha
tendremos este grupo metilo que aparece
en el segundo carbono si empezamos de
derecha a izquierda tendremos dos grupos
metilo en nuestro segundo carbono verdad
entonces no podremos simplemente
utilizar lo que se conoce como la
o bueno no podemos asignarle digamos las
reglas que pusimos al inicio verdad
tenemos 2
estas dos en numeración es distintas que
nos dan que el primer digamos el primer
sustituyen te aparece en el 2 entonces
vamos a hacer estos dos ejemplos vamos a
vamos a seguir enumerando 3 4 5 6 7 y 8
verdad 3 4
5 6 7 8 entonces vamos a identificar
primero cuáles son los grupos sustituye
entes que tenemos entonces tenemos si
nos damos cuenta son puros grupos metilo
verdad todos estos son grupos metilo
ahora bien si nosotros hiciéramos la
enumeración de esta forma de esta forma
tendríamos un penta metil verdad venta
metil que aparece en el 23 y de hecho
aparecen dos veces en el tres y dos
veces en el siete verdad venta venta
metil octano ok ahora si lo hiciéramos
de esta forma tendríamos 22 nos el 3 no
ahora sería 6
6 y 7 venta metí la venta metil octano
ahora cuál de estos dos tendremos que
seleccionar por si nos damos cuenta los
dos
inician digamos con una ramificación o
un grupo sustituye ente en el carbono 2
sin embargo en el segundo número tenemos
aquí un 3 y aquí un 2
entonces según nuestra regla nuestra
regla nos dice que hay que enumerar la
cadena para asignar a los sustituyó
antes el número más pequeño posible
verdad entonces este de aquí sería la
forma correcta de nombrar a esta
molécula y este a está digamos regleta
que acabamos de descubrir es es lo que
se le conoce como el primer punto de
diferencia muy bien el primer punto de
diferencia y es muy útil y lo vamos a
estar usando a menudo vamos a ver este
siguiente ejemplo aquí ahora vamos a
empezar a trabajar con ciclohexano los
ciclohexano son justamente estructuras
moleculares
de estos hidrocarburos
donde tenemos arreglos cíclicos o
digamos en forma de polígonos de estos
átomos de carbono entonces lo primero
que hay que hacer es nuevamente
identificar cuál es la estructura con la
cadena más larga y si nos damos cuenta
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 verdad aquí
tenemos 6 átomos de carbono lo cual nos
da nuestra estructura más larga que si
comparamos con esta de aquí aislada está
solo tiene 2 verdad entonces este de
aquí va a ser un ciclo hexano
ciclohexano
ahora qué es lo que seguía pues
enumerarlos para que aparezcan los
grupos sustituye entes en el número más
pequeño y si nos damos cuenta habría que
iniciar aquí con el primero y podríamos
irnos en la enumeración digamos hacia la
el sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj o justo en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj aquí no importa
realmente porque sólo tenemos un grupo
sustituye ente de hecho déjenme ponerlo
así 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 verdad ahora
finalmente identificamos qué grupo
sustituye entes tenemos aquí tenemos un
grupo estilo unido en el primer átomo de
carbono verdad entonces tendremos
uno útil ciclohexano y a veces este uno
puede sobrar porque no tenemos más
sustituye entes entonces queda claro que
tiene que ser el primero verdad vámonos
con otro ejemplo y aquí nuevamente pongo
dos copias para ver los distintos casos
que podemos tener entonces en este caso
podríamos tener aquí el primero o acá
verdad podría estar aquí el primero o
aquí el primero verdad en este caso si
ponemos aquí el primero tendremos que
enumerar hacia la derecha o si tenemos
aquí el primero tendríamos que enumerar
hacia la izquierda cual tendríamos
nosotros que seleccionar entonces
nosotros tendríamos que seleccionar este
de aquí cuando tenemos el primer átomo
de carbono aquí porque eso nos da dos
grupos metilo en el primero verdad si
nosotros tenemos aquí sólo tenemos un
grupo sustituye ente en el primero así
que vamos a eliminar este caso
y eliminamos este caso y en cualquiera
de los dos pues tendremos que se va a
ser el primero y antes debimos haber
visto cuál era la estructura más grande
que si nos damos cuenta es este ciclo de
seis átomos de carbono entonces este es
un ciclo hexano verdad esto es un ciclo
hexano
ciclohexano muy bien entonces tenemos
una disyuntiva empezamos o más bien
seguimos enumerando hacia la dirección
de las manecillas del reloj verdad
podría ser algo así dos tres cuatro
cinco y seis o enumeramos en la
dirección contraria sería dos tres
cuatro cinco y seis entonces vamos a ver
tenemos aquí un grupo dos grupos metilo
verdad y acá un grupo de ti lo cual va a
ser la correcta pues tendremos que hacer
que esta enumeración tenga el número más
pequeño y aquí nos damos cuenta que este
grupo estilo coincide con el tercer
átomo de carbono de la cadena mientras
que este sería en el 5 entonces el
correcto sería este del lado izquierdo y
podemos ver que tenemos grupos metilo y
grupos de tilo según el orden alfabético
pues gana el grupo estilo y entonces
tendremos un
3 útil verdad y tenemos 2
metidos aquí perdón es un guión entonces
sería un dimetil ciclohexano y ojo algo
que hay que notar es que cuando vamos a
hacer el orden alfabético solo nos
fijamos en la letra primera del grupo
del grupo sustituye ente que estamos
considerando nunca hay que considerar
los prefijos los prefijos quedan fuera
de nuestra regla alfabética muy bien
entonces vamos a proseguir con otro
ejemplo más para tener más más y más
ejemplos de cómo hacer la nomenclatura
de estas de estos hidrocarburos entonces
nuevamente tenemos un ciclo y nuestra
estructura más larga es esta de aquí que
tiene cinco átomos de carbono entonces
tendríamos un ciclo pantano ciclo venta
no en cualquiera de los dos casos porque
son iguales vamos a ver cuál sería la
forma correcta de llamarlo ahora tenemos
otra vez una disyuntiva porque este
podría ser el primero o podría ser
déjame ponerlo más bien
este podría ser el primero verdad o
podría ser este el primero si este fue
el primero el digamos la forma de
enumerar este este ciclo sería hacia
esta dirección para que aquí aparezca el
número más pequeño y en este caso sería
al revés verdad entonces podríamos tener
un 1 steel 2 metil verdad algo así o al
revés
entonces si nos damos cuenta ambos
tienen un grupo sustituyen t en el
primero y en el segundo entonces aquí el
primer punto de diferencia falla no no
nos puede decir cuál es el que nos
conviene así que vamos a saltarnos ahora
a la regla alfabética verdad aquí por
ejemplo sería un 1 útil 2 metil ciclo
pentano mientras que aquí sería un 2
útil verdad 1 metil ciclo pentano
entonces esto ya está acomodado digamos
en orden alfabético pero aquí el
correcto es este verdad porque ya que la
el primer punto de diferencia no nos
dice nada tenemos
elegir el que tenga la letra digamos la
primera letra en el sentido del alfabeto
y esa es la verdad en el que nos da el 1
debemos compararlo después con el orden
alfabético y ahí es cuando decimos que
nos saltamos a la regla alfabética y por
eso es que este es el nombre correcto
según la nomenclatura de iupac para esta
molécula vamos a ver un último ejemplo
este de aquí entonces si nos damos
cuenta otra vez tenemos que hacer la
selección de nuestra estructura más
larga y aquí es muy fácil ver que
tenemos esta estructura muy larga que es
de 7 carbonos entonces este de aquí
sería un eta no vamos a bajar un poquito
más aquí este sería un ept ano y la
diferencia que tenemos con los casos
anteriores es que aquí tenemos un
con una estructura cíclica verdad no
pensaría lo mejor que si tienes un ciclo
partimos de ahí pero no tenemos que
elegir la estructura más larga entonces
aquí está esta estructura cíclica sería
un grupo alquilo verdad y que se
encuentra en el carbono 4 y eso nos da
un 4 ciclo ciclo propio que es el de 3
ciclo propio esta no verdad si fuera en
el otro sentido entonces sería por
ejemplo si si tuviéramos un ciclo más
largo como en lo que hemos visto en los
casos anteriores pues los demás grupos
sustituye entes serían grupos alquilo
verdad entonces si tuviéramos dos
estructuras con la misma longitud pero
uno es cíclico y el otro es digamos
lineal entonces quién gana es el ciclo y
en ese caso sería un al kiel sí que
ciclo ciclohexano perdón un al kiel
ciclo arcano digamos en general es decir
tendremos un ciclo un ciclo que tiene
ramificaciones